a rue ha I am 24 years hi Uncle Bobby
I'm 24 hours old recently graduated from
University but with no job my question
for you is would you like kalila [ __ ]
you with a strap-on
thanks Roja just sticker time no no
because there's no pleasure in it for me
I know that you guys believe that
there's pleasure spots inside the
butthole but I don't believe it either
so um for me it would just be suffering
and that's it
I take it back I think there are
pleasure things all right so I've never
put anything in my butt but I used to do
this when I was little
are you sure about that yes I used to
hold my poo I don't fight said this on
here I used to hold my poo and Tom
sweating
I used to plank facing up and hide under
tables and my grandparents would look
for me later where's DG boy and they'd
find me drenched in sweat smiling you
know my position holding my poo and I
never knew why I did it yeah what has
your gay wanted a brown log of my water
I think that's it that was a weirdest
[ __ ] thing I was a child ever I said
when were kids we could do whatever you
want
next bro except that yogurt that's why
are you getting so defensive listen hold
my poo but it's not a thing I've never
heard of that before you know what be
know I'll be honest I surveyed people no
one else has done it I get it but all
right all right so you held let me just
get it straight
okay because maybe I even heard it wrong
mmm so this is what I thought you said
go ahead which I don't think this is
what you said let me hear it so you had
to take a [ __ ] yes but you didn't you
clinch your butthole and hold the [ __ ]
then you would hide from your
grandparents right and play a game while
you're clinching your [ __ ] I'm under a
piano and under a piano table and you're
you have a smile on your face and you're
arching your back like this no it's
actually like this way what is this
concave I don't know what you're doing
I'm just tightening whatever does that
you know I'm sharing it right so then
and then they would go GG where are you
boy where are you and then they would
find you and what you would just [ __ ]
right then and there
no I dislike would they be like what are
you doing I have to go poon like then go
poo and they pull me that is literally
if my okay i'ma see if your kid does
this would I if I was a grandfather and
my grandkid did that yeah I would call
the hospital right away and get you like
checked in because it's [ __ ] some
weird [ __ ] right there dude just try it
once but pooing itself is so pleasurable
it is but that's it fellas but you will
know that but then I when I did it it
was like whoa I'm just saying try this
next time you have to do it hold your
poo yeah 15 minutes past doing it yeah
so you sweat yeah then go in the toilet
take a [ __ ] look what happens well you
know what since I've never tried that
before I'm gonna try it thank you for I
make judgement for being open kalila I
you know I podcast listeners every
practice I pass well you're not being
old coz I like the feeling of booing I
don't like the feeling I get what he's
saying that he's holding it so that when
it does happen it's like when people
like same with orgasms they tried to
orgasm right away and what if they let
it build and then when it happens it's
Eureka or tricky the next question
[Music]